[Music]
i'm always
her delivered a powerful performance at
the 2021 oscars
performing fight for you the song she
wrote for the judas and the black
messiah soundtrack
during the into the spotlight
pre-telecast special
[Music]
the 23 year old grammy winner who looked
stunning in a gold sequin jumpsuit
started off singing while also playing
the drums
she then took center stage where she was
joined by over a dozen musicians
[Music]
[Music]
is
her's performance also paid tribute to
judas and the black messiah
in a poignant way the singer's stunning
vocals were intercut with remarks from
the subject of the movie
black panther's leader fred hampton as
his image was projected
on stage
the fred hampton story is not taught in
schools at all and that's very sad you
know so
we literally had a little history lesson
and
writing the song just kind of connected
that time and now and the fact that
we're still in that struggle we're still
in that fight
e.t spoke with her at the 2021 grammys
just moments before she took home
two trophies she explained what it was
like creating such a meaningful
and purposeful track like fight for you
we were listening to like marvin gaye
and curtis mayfield
and that's my favorite era anyways so
the fact that we got to tap
into it it was it was kind of easy and
then when we got to the message it was
like
okay everybody's fighting for something
we're all trying to fight for our people
for love for
all of these things and that's kind of
how we got to this this groove and and
we wanted a hopeful
you know we did we didn't want it to be
sad we wanted to feel hopeful
coming off a massive year of success
performing at the super
bowl and oscars plus two grammy wins
it begs the question what's next for her
whatever god has planned you know the
fact that i'm doing what i love
is what it is and i'm just gonna keep
going and keep keep
living and walking through my purpose
and i think that's going to take me
further than anything